[Music]
Janelle Brown making progress in her
year of health I'm finding so much value
and so much richness and deepness and it
increases as the years
seem for me at least check out the
Sister Wives Stars impressive splits
during a pilates class she's keeping it
real and what she calls an unfiltered
photo which she admits was scary to
share see Janelle finds social media
brutal but she says that won't stop her
from being authentic even if her form on
the reformer is as she puts it less than
perfect so I find real value in it
Janelle's 2023 Health kick follows her
split from husband Cody Brown in
December they confirmed their so-called
spiritual marriage was over after 29
years together Janelle has made it
pretty clear to me that she's
enjoying her life without me we've been
separated for several months what
so are you separated yes we're separated
it's easy to start pointing the other
ugly finger a blame and so no I don't
just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around since then Janelle's
been putting herself first and sharing
this new chapter of her life routine is
good especially when you're traveling
doing something kind of normal doing
something kind of physical with your
body
it's empowering and it makes it feel
like all is right with the world and get
this the mom of six reportedly has lost
over 100 pounds look at the before and
after and next up Janelle's got big
plans for summer we're starting to think
about all the fun vacations that
um
you know in involve possibly a swimsuit
possibly some activity outside she's not
the only sister wife making big Life
Changes Christine and Mary are moving
forward too they also ended their
relationships with Cody in the last year
and I really just feel like this is the
path I'm supposed to be on now like
Janelle Christine's focused on Fitness
staying active too living life to the
fullest with her friends and as for me
lately I've been focusing Less on doing
what they say I can't do and more on
doing
whatever the hell I want you just keep
working at it you know you keep working
at the relationships and you just keep
doing all the things and you just keep
improving yourself that's the thing that
I find you know you just work through it
and then you get to a point that's good
[Music]
thank you